[Applause]
ally i'm so excited that you're here
you're so
darn funny and amazing um would you like
to hit some headlines with us
let's hit them baby all right ross kick
it off all right allie
we are going to kick it off with the
latest on jeopardy usa today reports the
show's announced a lineup of celeb guest
hosts who are going to just do it for a
little bit just for funsies they include
anderson cooper
savannah guthrie and our friend dr oz i
know
um and i remember aly and i want to ask
you specifically um howard stern was
talking to your husband george
stephanopoulos and he actually said that
george would make a good uh host for
jeopardy
so can you break any news here has
george been offered
a gig all i can tell you is
that george is not that smart
so if he did host jeopardy he'd need an
earpiece and i'd be having to feed him
which gets complicated um i think george
i think george is is extremely busy with
gma
and his sunday show and of course all my
sexual needs so
i don't fit anything else in his
schedule i mean
you know maybe grey's anatomy once in a
while but uh
no he's he's a busy guy i think you
could do it too though
oh i would love that i've seen you do so
i mean i just love watching you i am all
ears and all eyes
oh my gosh maybe we should start doing
segments on on the drew show where we do
our own jeopardy
why do why do we have to wait for abc to
come to us
i mean i love answering trivia questions
and i love you
and we love games so okay
it's a no-brainer all right let's we'll
uh offline as soon as this segment is
over
um i um by the way i love how your
husband link just
gets you and loves your humor and
celebrates you it's such a good
we couldn't be married if that was not
uh the dynamic because
people always people were so and they
still are so curious about us
yeah and i always say like you don't
want two of me like if i married carrie
to carrot top it would be
a nightmare yeah and you know if george
married
some astro scientist with no personality
but it'd be a little bland at a dinner
party so i think it's i think it's a
good mix
you know and now we have two daughters
that have a you know kind of a little
bit of both i always say they have
his brain and my legs and if it were the
other way around they'd be screwed
maybe that's what you need drew is like
like the counterbalance to you you know
what i mean i know
what you're talking about like joe
manginello was like you need someone who
can one-up you i was like i think the
earth might implode
um maybe something to like mellow you
out and like not that you're
but you know what i mean like the
opposite of valium in the form of a man
perfect um i have an emotional support
dog go ahead
i have one of those douglas yes um
i have a trivia question how often
should you
replace your hairbrush um
i know that i'm going to say the wrong
thing because i think i still have my
hair brush from freshman yuriko real
simple asked an
expert and they say that we should be
replacing our brushes
every six months to a year and
you should be deep cleaning the
barnacles off that bad boy
once a month barnacles barnacles
i know schluffing well like a whale i
have uh you know i
i've seen my girl so my girlfriend's
getting ready before we go out and like
i always say like i would never judge
you but you're disgusting because some
of them look like
like a true rat's nest ali how what's
the state of your brush
well the i think the state of my brush
is um it's a chia pet
kind of i haven't found any barnacle i
see i see live animals but
uh it's hard to tell because my
daughters take my brush too
so it's a little bit of it's a little
bit of everything ellie quickly tell us
about your podcast go ask ally and what
we can expect this season
this past season was all about how to
grow a teenager in a pandemic
this season is all about how to grow a
relationship
you know in a pandemic in in a crazy
world
and i i mean growing a relationship with
a sibling
with a spouse with the lover with an
aging parent i mean with the ups guy
and i've i've actually found that i i'm
doing an episode about growing a
relationship with yourself
because during the pandemic every night
with my two daughters i would say let's
have an ice cream bar and i went to the
doctor and my cholesterol was like 310
which is you know i shouldn't be alive
and i realized
i'm just not taking care of myself at
all because i'm zooming
and so you can't get the whole picture
and i just haven't been healthy at all
so i
i stopped the ice cream for a while and
i started walking with my emotional
support dog cooper who's my other
husband
and sort of started to get healthy um
but i realized
so many don't you guys find that so many
relationships during this time have been
fractured or you're not seeing your
girlfriends as much
and maybe you don't need all these
people in your life maybe you just need
a core group so
i've had everybody glenn and doyle
everybody my my
my bestie marishka hargite like so many
people weighing in
on how we grow these healthy
relationships right now
i love that you're talking about the
relationship with yourself too and
reevaluating i think this pandemic has
made us re-evaluate everything
listen everyone is going to be in
relationships throughout their life
i love that you're covering all
different types of them because there
are all different types out there but we
are always navigating relationships
and everything you just said was so
astute i'm just gonna hang on your every
word
ali wentworth her podcast go ask ali is
out now with new episodes coming in
march and i can't thank you enough and
let's sidebar about more
[Music]
more
you